اصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا قال فيه ان
البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير بعد قيام الدعم
السريع بحشد قواتها في العاصمه وبعض المدن
ما يدق ناقوس الخطر واضاف البيان ان
تحركات قوات الدعم السريع داخل العاصمه
والولايات تمت دون موافقه القوات المسلحه
ومخالفه لمهام ونظام عمل تلك القوات وقال
البيان ان استمرار تحركات الدعم السريع
سيؤدي الى مزيد من الانقسامات والتوترات
التي تقود الانفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد وفق
تعبير البيان
وجب علينا ان ندقنا قوس الخطر
بان بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن هذه التحركات
والانفتاحات تمت دون موافقه قياده القوات
المسلحه او مجرد التنسيق معها
مما اثار الهلع والخوف في اوساط مواطنين
وفاقم من المخاطر الامنيه
وزاد من التوتر بين القوات النظاميه
مواطنين الكرام
لم تنقطع محاولات القوات المسلحه في ايجاد
الحلول السلميه لهذه التجاوزات وذلك حفاظا
على الطمانينه العامه وعدم الرغبه في نشوب
صراع مسلح يقضي على الاخضر واليابس
وجدد الجيش السوداني في بيانه تمسك القوات
المسلحه بدعم ما جرى التوافق عليه لدعم
الانتقال السياسي محذرا القوى السياسيه
مما سماه المزايده على مواقف القوات
النظاميه
تجدد القوات المسلحه تمسكها بما تم
التوافق عليه في دعم الانتقال السياسي
وفقا لما جاء في الاتفاق الايطالي وتحذر
القوه السياسيه من مخاطر المزايده بمواقف
القوات المسلحه الوطنيه
التي لم تبخل في سبيل تحقيقها بتقديم
المهج والارواح رخيصه لينعم السودان
بالامن والاستقرار